we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let's go to our caller from the 2 4 0
area code who has been holding on for a
while
caller from 2 4 0 do we have let's see 2
4 0 seems to be glitching here no here
you are yeah go ahead 2 4 0 hi David
this is Charles from Maryland great go
ahead
so the past few weeks I have been paying
close attention to the polls and from
what I've seen Trump's approval ratings
has started to go back up a Rasmussen
poll had him at 49 and the you'll click
Real Clear Politics average of polls had
him at the mid 40s which is pretty
incredible concerning the fact that he
was hovering in the mid thirties not too
long ago yep so my question to you is do
you think he's finally turned things
around and if so what does that mean for
the upcoming midterm elections so a
couple things number one Rasmussen never
had him in the mid 30s Rasmussen well
Rasmussen always has him the highest I
tend to look at either the 538 average
of approval polls and also the Gallup
daily tracking poll but you're right
there has been a slight trickle up it's
not hugely statistically significant
when you consider a plus plus or minus 3
percent 3 percentage point margin of
error but you're right I mean there has
been on average it's been sitting a
little bit higher I actually don't think
it's that meaningful for the 2020
election because I believe the 2020
election is really going to come down to
turnout I've pointed out how Trump could
actually win reelection
with low 30s or even high twenties
percent approval because of the way that
we have an electoral college system and
we only have about 50 percent turnout so
I am less concerned about whether his
approval is 37 or 40 then I am about
enthusiasm and turnout for both the 2018
election and the eventual 2020 election
that's what I'm looking more closely at
okay thank you all right no problem that
was it that was a simple one I guess
people talking about how Trump has a
basement you know like 33 percent of
supporters that will always stick with
him yeah I think he also has a ceiling
to like he can't really get too much
past like 40 percent now maybe maybe
maybe at the most
and now it's I think the highest because
just gave his State of the Union address
could be and made many people thought of
that as presidential yeah there's uh
there's probably something to that